[Musique]
une rumeur court qu'un homme des plaines
traîne dans le coin pour tuer ses gosses
il serait revenu pour enlever toutes les
graines de son existence
le type forteresse avec une crosse en
ivoire un peu comme celui que vous avez
tu as quel âge déjà
vous connaissez ma mère
elle n'est pas de toi
on dit que tu as été maudit par les
Cheyenne que tu vas mourir de la main de
ton fils
celui qui a fait ça à mes hommes
qui sait ce qu'il va faire avec ma
gatine
vous savez où est le directeur
il a tué beaucoup de monde
et je suis sa mère
dis-moi où est ton gamin laisse-le
tranquille
poursuit un tipi a été vu dans les
parages il tue ses propres gosses
parle-moi de l'autre son jumeau il
s'appelle comment
le renseigné vous ne savez pas ce qui
approche
en ville je veux savoir où ils sont
allés un tas de jeunes gens passent par
ici vous allez avoir du sang sur les
mains
tout à fait ça ton père tu dois quitter
la ville il te cherche j'ai pas peur de
lui
[Musique]
ça fait ouais mon père en effet mais
vous devez me promettre une chose et
c'est quoi tu es le pour de bon
[Musique]